so far
it's tracking as an 85 million box
office film
uh lots and lots of pre-sales gone on uh
odin said earlier in the week they sold
nearly two hundred thousand pre-tickets
uh
other chains are reporting the same so i
think people are going to come back i
think it's going to be
a big weekend for cinema
and uh we're all very very excited i
mean the papers are just full of bond
today lots of five star reviews so i
think it's going to be the boost to
bring people back
i mean we've had a few decent uh
openings since cinemas were allowed to
reopen peter rabbit of course black
widow how have things been for you
they've been good lots of i mean
initially a bit slow in
may and june when we first opened but
gradually seeing an uptick uh in
advertiser interest and audiences
audiences peaking a bit quiet last
weekend but the weekend before a bomb
did no one puts film out the weekend
before a bond because everyone's just
kind of getting themselves ready for
their big film that we've waited so long
for
i mean we were speaking earlier on in
the program to marie mclennan from m c
sartre he said ad budgets were up across
the piece what's been going on with your
ad rates well as you know we were closed
for much of last year so um
so the only way is up for us but we've
had
huge advertiser interest in bond
lots of advertisers are interested in
the subsequent films like june west side
story the spider-man that's coming
there's a spider-man coming out um
art films like the french dispatch so
we are very very confident about having
a very very good uh q4 in cinema
and how are the numbers right now
comparing with 2019 in the pre-pandemic
era
uh
they're where we thought they would be
they're you know just above 80 odd
percent not quite back but that's
because certain markets like northern
ireland northern ireland's restrictions
for social distancing don't come off
until actually just before bond opens
they stop tomorrow some cinemas are
still operating social distancing just
to recognize the concerns of their
customers so we but we are happy with
the trajectory of admissions as are most
uh most uh cinema chains
and are you seeing a difference in the
types of advertisers that are booking
space with you
well it all changes by the film so you
always get the bombed die-hards um who
love bond uh some you know normally
brands that are associated with the film
or know that it will deliver audiences
but so often um the pattern of
advertising is determined by
um the type of film so you'll get a
completely different advertiser in the
downton abbey film than we would in west
side story because it's about the
audience that you deliver
so i mean forgive me for not knowing
this and it may well be a trade secret
i'm asking you to divulge here but
presumably for something like bond you
would ratchet up the rates because
there's only so many adverts that can
run before the screening of a film and
you know you could presumably for
something like this you can get people
to pay top dollar
well i couldn't possibly comment but
let's put it this way we're all very
happy at pearl and dean about the
advertisers and the revenue that we've
generated with bond
i mean if we'd gone to bond cinema i
mean i remember going to see uh
moonraker 40 odd years ago at the cinema
for example i mean in those days it
would have all been uh tobacco
advertising and things like that i mean
how much of a loss was that to uh cinema
advertising
well it was a while ago so not that much
and what we found is that's been
replaced by newer categories like tech
companies you know people like apple
google facebook uh twitter advertising
with us
um
so as one category has kind of ended and
other ones and other ones have kind of
emerged that spend money with us and
digital changed the way that cinema
works a lot because we can drop ads in
really late as opposed to when we're on
35 mil which took you know which was
that whole those whole cans you know
that are always famous and everyone
always says oh this is what cinema is
like it isn't anymore it's all computers
so
no as that's dropped off we've had we've
had other revenue sources come up and uh
the number of films has increased so 350
before the start of digital now you get
something like 800 odd releases so it
allows you to segment your audience more
and appeal to different advertisers
and catherine you've been quite vocal in
the recent past about inclusivity the
need for diversity in the industry i
mean are you satisfied with the way that
the makers of the bond franchise have
sort of softened them up i mean he's not
the sort of sexist old uh ball that he
once was
well i think audiences have changed they
expect a different type of bond someone
is more reflective of of this society
and
uh
this film is true to the spirit of bond
but recognises the changes in society
i mean what's not to love